hey guys this is
Alisia it's been a
while but there have been quite a bit of
things on my
mind
um many of you have seen the uh well now
viral video about me
choosing to reject the Cheesecake
Factory
because I wanted more from my
date
I want to well let me say this is
interesting to
me that just how a moment in time
right can shape how so many view
you
pause ain't there anything
worse CRA she's crazy that when someone
talks slow to say
nothing that didn't trigger you I mean
if you going to be crazy just hurry up
with it hurry with you crazy yeah we a
got time
to
so uh isn't it
crazy the way
that people can judge
you based off your actions isn't
that
crazy I just got through one sentence
let me finish my second one I I finish
one sentence let me finish my second
one
The Cheesecake
Factory just like hey yo let's move
hurry up with your crazy is this going
somewhere let's go let's play this
it's
not and
so I want to talk about I'm trying to
remember I bear with me guys I wrote
down some notes so I can remember
everything I want to say where's your
notes yeah where's your notes oh my
D I've seen and heard
um many a Horror Story men and women not
just women men and
women
and I wanted to make
[Music]
sure
that all right she not saying nothing
bro I don't got time let's just move on
toie not saying nothing she not
saying nothing got mad she not saying
nothing why you mad because they going
to be mad you think I'm mad I know the
viewers mad they mad they mad with me I
was mad when I saw this too yeah I feel
like everybody needs to be mad equally
okay listen we skipping this one let's
just go to the interview we'll see
something there oh to because this was
unwatchable uh well uh since
I was on the video kind of unexpected uh
I might not have put my best foot
forward you know and so I feel like well
I I've not really met anyone since who
uh I've really gotten to get to know
like that
because a lot of women they might have
seen the video or might have heard from
it or maybe a friend of them has seen
the video and shares it with them MH and
so they kind of had this image of me
front based on the video absolutely and
it hasn't really help okay exactly it's
like they they might think everything
about me is reflected in that video and
I don't think it is and uh but yeah it's
it's been difficult sure sure sure and
it's even before this you know dating
has already been difficult for me I
imagine your views kind of clash what
you're looking for what they're looking
for yeah I think so cuz I mean I think
in general my values kind of reflect
wanting to build something that lasts
yes sir and I want to make sure that
anyone that I meet is willing to build a
really strong Foundation uh based on our
mutual values and I think it it in
general a lot of the people that I meet
uh either they don't have time to set
towards building something like that or
they just don't want to cuz you know
they're younger they want to experience
you know casual dating or whatever it is
and and it's just not something that I'm
looking for right now understood
understood so obviously guys Jay's
saying that they have a negative you and
him a negative light when comes to
Dayton when I saw Jay I saw someone who
was making some excellent points who
knew what he want and he's actually now
like a gigachad in the uh manosphere
world in the red pill Community the
brothers being mentioned everywhere for
the way he handled that conversation um
now I'm going to ask Alicia as well
because during during this conversation
Alicia
Alicia maybe he's just being a good guy
so he's correcting the host's
pronunciation of her names very nice of
him
gentlemen I certainly would have done
the same
would you what made an effort to correct
the guy on her name yes sir I mean I
want to make sure that everybody knows
the real
name so we know how much you're a piece
of it's pretty
[Laughter]
good Petty no no her name is not Alicia
it's Alicia get the horse name right yes
get the piece of name right I mean
cuz now you're out here calling someone
out of their name and it's not even
their name yeah no direct the negative
energy are the right person if you
believe in that and the mov and
everything is tough so yeah I that's why
it's really important and the positive
and a negative you've changed my mind I
will always pronounce people's names
right thank you thank you get that right
okay so Alicia you didn't seem to really
disagree with what you were saying now
you had a definitely a different opinion
before he gave you his his his mind
right but you seem very retive to it can
you explain to me kind of what you were
thinking and how you saw him in that
video cuz he saying they got to took him
a negative light what what do you think
well yes I I think once we had the
conversation I could see my role m in
the conf
okay okay um just back up a little bit
to be fair I mean I was always raised
that the man is supposed to cater to you
I mean you're courting me so Court me m
that means wherever I want to go you
take me whatever I want you buy
me can I say
it can I can I say it I need to do my
goles cuz apparently according to me
means something completely different who
are
you and also so who raised you nah be
yeah you're supposed to cour you're
supposed to court
but you got to give me something to
court
about if you want to be respected you
got to be giving me something to
respect that was not what it
was in that video it was nothing to
court that's courting you know I'm
looking for a provider so but after the
conversation I could see how there was a
lot of I okay and in in that exchange um
it was I was definitely very
self-centered and I can appreciate if I
do want someone to provide for me I at
least got to be a little bit nice
absolutely okay okay great so now I ask
you this based based on your idea of
dating before your conversation with Jay
how did you grow up who who also thinks
that way I'm sure you have friends who
think that way I've heard it a lot Ian
everybody I mean that's that's what the
man he's supposed to be the provider
absolutely so you know and I'm a
beautiful woman so I'm expecting to be
treated like royalty I mean come on so
that's what how do we treat him and
that's where that's
in the video now of course I'm sure you
think of it now but in the video you you
basically told him that you know you're
not going you know your value it would
be embarrassing for you to go inside a
Cheesecake Factory a lot of people like
Cheesecake Factory now so when I see
that video I'm thinking okay she must
have some friends who probably would
disagree with her going inside a
Cheesecake Factory PE group so probably
you I never live that oh my God if yeah
I would never live that D wow just the
cheesecake FR they wouldn't let you live
that D no I have image to
protect does not do that that I mean
that was you know that was my circle
though that's how I mean that's what
that's how we
you want people to treat you like
royalty if you want people to treat you
like royalty like that you got to date a
peasant I'm using your analogies right
there you got to date a
peasant but if you're dating a king he's
going to treat you as an
equal cuz both of y'all
royalty I'm not going to do everything
it's mutual
respect there there's mutual thing
that's going on if you come an hour you
don't come down after an hour you're not
royalty like I have to be a peasant I'm
dating you that means that I have to I'm
at The Peasant and I got to upgrade the
no man I got to give you the respect
like I am as well and that's a no now
here we are a few weeks later I'm sure
you had some time to think about what
you guys discussed in the car I'm sure
You' had some time to think about it
before I ask you any questions have you
guys had a second date no no no second
dates okay okay so I start with you J
cuz the dude is nice he didn't yell at
her anything she know she had something
so she going to try to do that yeah and
he's going to say yeah well I mean as a
black woman I'mma go there I mean as a
black woman um we're really tired of
having to settle um we want to be
treated well M we want that soft life so
that's what I thought I was going after
no me no no
no
I just want to ask you do you think that
women from other cultures would lose
their mind if we took them to the
Cheesecake
Factory do you think like everyone's
getting taken to festar restaurants and
then black women are getting taken to
McDonald's that really what you think is
happening don't drag black women this
this is your mess this is yours alone
don't be talking about oh I'm here to
fight for women no no boo boo you here
to fight for yourself okay cuz they
plenty black women who go to The
Cheesecake Factory ain't got no problem
with it so don't bring everybody else
into your
Shenanigans okay how what I understand
is a part of having a soft life is being
cooperative being soft not beinga right
actually being soft right being
receptive being sweet being Pleasant
right because we do understand the value
of of resources but it can't be just
something for a lifestyle resources a
man's resources is not just for a
woman's experiences and traveling and
the lifestyle they live with marriage
for providing for the family and the
children and that's why she she should
seek a man and you know respect his
resources or prioritize his resources
not just for what it can do for her
right and so when you were in the
beginning of it you was just saying I'm
not doing it seemed really selfish right
and I appreciate it when I saw the video
myself that's one of the things I
covered as wow she's I've never I've
never seen a woman that receptive to uh
being accountable right and you were uh
but Jay didn't want he didn't want to go
out on the date he wanted to discontinue
that date and he wanted to take it on to
the house um Jay is that your first time
stopping the date uh Midway through and
going back home or yeah something like
that's I'm sorry at least that that's
the first time I've really like put my
foot down to that kind of extent but
it's not like an an isolated incident
you know like I I've gone on dates with
several people now even before her where
it's they they had very specific things
they were looking for in a boyfriend or
whatever and uh even with my own circles
right and that that's just not something
that I'm looking for because I was
raised like like we were talking about
how she was raised whereas with me like
my family like we we've passed down the
name for ages and we're a very
close-knit strong family uh you passed
down your your your first thing Jay
father's and father how Generations
probably um I mean I I couldn't really
count it myself I the thing is like I'm
from India you know and the partition
happened where like India was separated
from Pakistan and a lot of my family
were on both sides of that and we had to
come back together and we had to it was
very important for us to stay strong
after the fact at the time maybe we
didn't care as much about creating this
Legacy but ever since it's like that's
been one of the strongest parts of our
family is the importance in creating our
Legacy and with that in mind like I've
grown up with the idea that I want a
strong family here now that I'm living
in America the only kind of
relationships I seek are ones where that
is the only value that is the biggest
value that is the most important thing
for the other person as well as for me
wow that's that's actually powerful so
your family going through all that they
did it caus you guys to really idealize
relationships right and specifically
relationships that last absolutely
absolutely so here you are in America
daily and mostly in our culture where
you said earlier you were a black woman
of course we have been through some
things right in in our culture here in
the states and throughout the whole
diaspora I like using that word but a
lot of times our culture have been
stripped and we haven't yet be to
idealize relationships you know so we're
more so going along with the flow so
here he is in America and he's meeting a
woman who's in America and she sees
dating the way Americans see dating and
so I can see the clash in that you know
um he looking at he's looking at you as
if that selfish you're looking at him as
if you know he's treating you beneath
your worth value so here's what I want
to do guys I want to go back a bit can
tell me how you met can want you to tell
me how you guys met so I I was in
Midtown and like I barely even have time
to go out with friends and all that but
it was a really close friend's birthday
so I went to get some drinks for the
first time in ages and I saw this
beautiful woman who it seemed like every
other guy in the bar was either
intimidated by or too shy to talk to and
I thought what the hell why not um and
she was you know minding her own
business and I asked her you know her
name Lisa and I thought that's a
beautiful name and even despite how loud
it was in the bar we were still able to
talk a little here and there and uh I
got her number and she had to go and so
we kept talking after that for a little
bit and then like a week later I asked
her you want to go out I to this to this
restaurant yeah
okay I'll tell you what I think most of
this is about she difficult
yes um I really just
think is she somebody who would never go
into Cheesecake Factory it depends on
the
guy I think for the right guy she would
good homie shorter than her she probably
doesn't seem as just as
attractive you need to put up for all
that the fact that you're short and to
this and that so mind you she made him
wait an hour why is she making him wait
an hour because she don't seem as all
that why is she being so demanding on
the date in regards to going out to this
fancy restaurant cuz she don't seem as
all that so she said if you want to get
with me who is royalty you going to have
to work the way she uses all of her
language she sees him as beneath her
peasant
he has to provide I am royalty you need
to do whatever I want whenever I want
Ires how disrespectful I am to your time
or whatever give me a third of your
Harvest she's here and he's here peasant
okay and it doesn't help that for him
his demeanor he's a little bit soft
spoken his body language a little bit
closed in you know he wasn't a pushover
on the date because eventually he did
leave which is good and he voiced his
concerns which I think is great but the
way he carries himself makes him look
like that peasant I think what it really
comes down to is not only she a
difficult person but she had a dynamic
where she thought she was substantially
better than the main she was with and as
a result felt like she could act like
however she wanted came to find out the
internet came to see the video that she
herself self snitched on and uh her
behavior is not okay well at least we
got her answer it's not fake no I didn't
think it was fake there's a particular
Behavior to somebody
who doesn't really give a about you
or doesn't really care that shows
himself they're late engagements they
don't give an explanation they act
entitled they don't properly apologize
they don't make restitution what's
restitution I'll give you guys an
example if I'm supposed to go on a date
with a girl and I can so my job is to
immediately afterwards offer an
alternate datee or an alternate time to
give a proper heads up before the date
to say I can't make it okay right that's
my responsibility if I up our
engagement I have to do that if somebody
cancels on you and doesn't make any
effort to make alternate plans they
don't really care like that you
understand
if you text somebody and they don't
respond within 24 hours the next time
they text you they got to give you you
know a little extra a little explanation
to let you know hey even though I wasn't
here for this time period for whatever
ex or whatever reason I understand I'm
so I'm going to do a little extra you
have to do that if you don't it just
shows you don't really care or you see
the person as
like that's what that means so that's
what this guy was to her and from all
accounts it seems like that's the case
that's really what it was the queen
thing and the peasant thing that's how
you broke it down but that's what it is
she really thought of herself there and
you're going to have to work give me
some of that if you're not going to
treat me as an equal from the jump from
the start it's not it's it's a dud man I
had a bar got his number and I told her
it would be surprise and I told her it
would be a
surprise and maybe that that might be a
a problem on my part you know it might
have raised the expectations a little
bit but I guess the surprise ended up
being Cheesecake Factory where right we
the original surprise was I I want to
get to that you had you had something
else planned for her right because of
how it even went to Cheesecake Factory
happen right yeah um can I just say
before I love the Cheesecake Factory and
it's a place that I've gone to for like
every birthday uh so like it wasn't just
like a random restaurant to me it was
also like a place that I've gone with my
family throughout my entire life and I
love Che so so you didn't so obviously
the uh because you guys were late she
wasn't ready you weren't able to take
her to the restaurant that you wanted to
take it to you figured I can't go wrong
with cheese cake f yeah it's my old
birthday restaurant you know luy she it
that's the lucky spot too at the perim
lucky spot okay we'll come back to that
I'm kidding with you at Lea yeah so Jay
you see Jay walking up to you in the bar
say Midtown he's walking up to you he's
going to talk with you there other guys
around you could you did you notice
those guys probably want to talk to you
did you did you see that yes I did so so
what made you say okay I'm going to give
this guy a chance what was it about him
well he was bold enough to come up and
talk to me for so yes I definitely am
attracted to confidence he just seemed
like he had a pure heart he was you know
very thoughtful engaging um
I mean the the only the only he won me
over he did win me over but I'm a tall
woman and so there wasn't necessarily
like that immediate attraction that's
you that's
you okay to be fair I already watch this
one doesn't matter it's still you yeah
but I already watch this one so listen
I'm psychic sometimes this is not one of
them times Hey listen go but it was in
line what I for the amount of times for
the amount of times that you didn't
watch the video so
yeah that's you okay but I did preat but
yes but as we began to talk it was his
it was really his heart that that made
me say I'll give this this gu try okay
is that where you draw your line is that
typically you don't date guys who are
guys have to be at least your height or
taller before you date them exactly so
see this is the attitude of like I gave
him a chance yeah he going take ball he
had the balls to talk to me CH but he
could have W that in McDonald's
you would have been sucking some be in
the parking lot yeah if the guy was
6'5 y it would have matter yeah no no sh
in the Box haries
Wendy's Mickey but good for him
these nuts good for him good for him at
the end of day you know some people are
just like this so I mean just stay away
from them anything else I'm walking away
all right let us know what you guys
think